So, as it turns out, our brain signals the release of different compounds...
...when we're in love.
Really, there's a whole lot of compounds,...
...but I'm going to tell you today about the main three.
They're all neurotransmitters which means it's affecting our nervous system.
And yes, they're a little bit addicting.
First, dopamine.
Dopamine is part of the reward system.
It makes you feel really happy.
It's addictive too.
You crave it.
In this case, it makes you want to be with that person a lot.
Next, serotonin.
Serotonin helps us regulate appetite as well as mood and muscle contraction.
It results in extra focus and compulsive thinking.
Basically, it causes you to think about that person all the time.
Finally, adrenaline.
Adrenaline is released in the brain's adrenal gland.
It circulates quickly in the blood and makes you focus on the task at hand,...
...elevates your heart and makes you sweat.
It's a stress molecule, right?
And of course, the fight-or-flight drug.
All right, now let's review.
The feeling of love comes from the hormones released from your brain.
These hormones affect your mood and actions.
If you understand this, you'll make wiser decisions.
For instance, scientists suggest not to make life-changing decisions...
...when you're under the influence of love chemicals.
So, there you have it.
The chemistry of love.